physics is about discovering what the
laws of nature are and we've gotten some
distance towards that we're not done but
we've gotten some good distance towards
that at the present time but once you
know what the laws of nature are another
kind of question unfolds itself which is
why are those the laws and not other
laws for example the laws that we
understand the standard model of
particle physics describes all the
fundamental particles their interactions
has about 30 numbers which you just have
to put in as a result of measuring them
by experiment the masses of the
different particles the quarks the
electrons neutrinos the strengths of the
fundamental forces various numbers like
that and the model works dramatically
well as the recent experiments the Large
Hadron colliders show why are those
numbers what they are in our universe
why is the master the electron what it
is and not 12 times larger or half the
size there are dozens of questions like
this so I develop cosmological natural
selection to try to give an evolutionary
account of this so that there would be a
history back before the Big Bang in
which these numbers could change and
evolve through a series of events like
the Big Bang and there could be an
explanation akin to natural selection
just like you want to know you know why
do people have two legs and not three
legs or five legs or four legs or six
legs there's an evolutionary reason for
that a certain kind of Fitness has been
improved over many many generations and
similarly that could be a notion of
fitness of the laws of nature should
approval in many generations and
cosmological natural selection was an
example of a theory of that kind I
realized that the only methodology we
had in science or the best methodology
we had science for explaining how
choices have made the system to relate
to a lot of structure because one of the
mysteries is why our universe is so
structured as it is on so many scales
from organic molecules of biomolecules
up to vast arrays of clusters of
galaxies is aa enormous structure on
such a wide range of scales and that
turns out to be tied to the values of
these constants
of the standard model of particle
physics and so why is that I realized
that the only methodology that was
really successful for explaining how
choices were made in nature such as to
lead to an improbable amount of
structure is natural selection so for
natural selection we need reproduction
and there was a hypothesis flying around
that the universe is reproduced through
black holes that inside black holes
rather than there being singularities
were time ends there were basically the
births of new reasons of space and time
which could become newly universes and I
took over that hypothesis and took over
the hypothesis that maybe the laws of
nature change slightly which has been
made by Johnny wheeler in the 1960s and
just added a little bit which is that
those changes should be very small so
that there could be a cumulation of
fitness leads to a prediction or an
observation that after many many
generations the population of universes
should be fine-tuned to maximize the
production of black holes and that has
further implications for things that we
can actually try to measure and disprove
experimentally so that's very briefly
the idea of cosmological natural
selection